-Oh, man, y'all always
turn me on, man.
Come on. We love you!
Everyone loves you. Come on.
-Yeah, The Roots is my thing.
That's my thing.
-You feel the --
You feel the love?
You feel the love
we all gave you out here?
-Yes, I feel it, man.
-Come on, bud. You look good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Right on.
-You look good, brother.
-To the beat, beat,
check it out.
-Oh! To the beat, beat,
-Yep.
-Have you ever released a song
or a rap or a...
You can sing.
-I can?
-Yeah.
-My dad --
Yeah, I'm a vocalist.
-Yeah, I know.
-I do vocals, yeah.
-Yeah.
-I sing.
It takes me away
from show business.
-Oh, so it's too distracting.
-Yeah. No, I do something else.
I've always wanted to be a Pip.
[ Laughter ]
Like,
Gladys Knight and The Pips.
I always --
More than the Temptations,
I wanted to be a Pip.
-Pip, yeah.
One of the Pips, yeah.
-Pips is the joints.
I think one of them
is my biological father.
[ Laughter ]
-You know,
can I just bring this up?
I know we were just
talking backstage,
but I don't want to do anything.
But you told me backstage
that you were almost
speaker of the House.
Is that --
-Yeah.
Yeah, I could've been speaker.
-I didn't know --
-I could have been.
My game is good.
-I know. I didn't --
How you think I got
my wife to marry me?
-Yeah.
-Lying.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-She did not want to know
the truth about me.
I'm telling you,
who could get the Democrats
and the Republicans together
better than ol' Trae Bae?
-That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah, you get Tracy Morgan
in there, get everyone together.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I could've been speaker.
-You're all --
-Plus, George Santos said
I would be perfect for the job.
And I believe him because
he invented breakdancing.
-That's right, he did.
[ Laughter ]
-I remember him out there doing
the backspins and all that.
George Santos.
-That was George Santos.
Absolutely.
He was one of the Pips.
The original Pips.
-You know, when I was in high
school, they called me Turbo.
I look just like Turbo
from "Breakin'."
-I remember Turbo.
-Yeah, Turbo.
-But I didn't know that you were
so involved in politics.
I didn't know -- I didn't --
-Yeah, me and Trump was tight.
Me and Trump was tight.
-I didn't know this.
-But he just came under fire
because he had got --
released some documents,
some secret documents.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, I'm close --
I was close to Trump.
He ain't never said
nothing to me.
[ Laughter ]
-He didn't tell you anything?
-One time, he came over
to the house,
and he had six boxes,
and it said "Top Secret" on it.
I said, "What's in these boxes?"
He said, "Don't worry about it."
[ Laughter ]
Dude, I ain't never said
nothing to me, man.
-Yeah, he didn't say anything
to you.
-I don't know nothing.
-Nothing. Absolutely.
-That's what I tell
the district attorney --
"I don't know nothing."
[ Laughter ]
-I know we're both Knick --
Knick fans.
You're a giant
New York Knick fan.
-Yeah, that's where
you're wrong.
'Cause I'm not --
I'm not a Knick fan.
I'm part of the organization.
-Oh.
-I'm part of -- I get taped up
when I go to games.
They tape me up
-You think you might play?
-I'm the best time-out caller
in the league.
I don't just call time-outs.
I do it certain ways.
[ Laughter ]
-Ooh.
Ooh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, that's a good one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how I call time-out.
-Yeah.
Do you get up?
Do you start yelling
at players and stuff?
We just had Julius Randle
on the show.
-Yeah, Ju-Boogie know me.
[ Laughter ]
Ju-Boogie know me.
-He does?
-Yes, when I need --
I'd love to hear him out there
grunting and going up
for rebounds.
And you right there
on the floor, you know?
So you hear him going for --
[ Loud grunting, shouting ]
-Yeah.
-I love that. Communication.
-That's why he should
be speaker of the House.
-The song -- yeah.
-Communication is key.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You all need communication.
-Can I ask -- here's you
and your beautiful daughter.
How's the baby?
-That's my stinker mama.
-Yeah.
How's she doing?
-First of all, these are
a little distracting for the...
[ Laughter ]
-I think it was distracting
for the players
because they lost that game.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
How's the baby?
How's how's your daughter?
-Who, Maven?
-How's Maven?
-Maven is my bubi?
-I know.
-She's the reason why I live,
man.
Yeah, I came out of
that coma for her.
She was only 10 months old, man.
-Wow.
-So I had to come out that coma
to be with my daughter.
She's great.
She wants to be an actor.
-She does?
-Yeah, I had her on my show.
She performed on "The Last OG,"
and she was on there,
and she was only,
like, 8 years old.
She dropped a line,
and in front of everybody,
she just said, "Line!"
-Really?
-Yeah. 'Cause that's what I do.
[ Laughter ]
-But that's great.
-I don't know none of my lines,
so I just say, "Line,"
all day long.
-Hey, you, uh...
I was talking about Halloween,
or you get into Halloween.
You said that you have
the scary basement
that you put on
for your kids.
-Every year, I turn my basement
of my mansion
into a haunted house
for my daughter.
-I mean, you really --
Look at these.
Look at these pictures.
This is for real.
-Yeah.
-Do you go --
-I don't go down there.
I just be upstairs making
franks and pork and beans.
That's what --
-Yeah.
that's my food -- cowboy food.
Franks and pork and beans.
-Yeah, you are a cowboy.
-Yeah. Me and Questlove.
Franks and pork and beans.
-Yeah, but he eat
chicken franks.
I eat beef franks.
-Franks and pork and beans
sounds like
three ingredients to me.
-That's what cowboys used to eat
on the tin pan.
-Mm.
-Yeah.
-On the open fire.
-Yeah, on an open fire.
That was me.
That was my
great-great-great-grandfather,
John Wayne.
-John Wayne.
[ Laughter ]
-My great-great-great
grandfather, John Wayne.
-How's your -- how's your movie,
by the way?
You're still working on
the superhero movie?
-Yeah, I'm bringing back
Black Bobcat back.
-Yeah.
Black -- Black Bobcat.
-'Cause that's what's making
money now, Marvel movies.
-So you have been working
on this -- "Black Bobcat"?
-Yeah, he sleeps a lot.
That's his superpower.
He sleeps a lot,
and he likes to lap milk.
[ Laughter ]
He leaps.
-Yeah. Oh, does he?
-Black Bobcat.
-Yeah, Black Bobcat.
He's got nine lives.
-Yeah. What are you gonna do?
-Likes to lap milk.
-This is actually something
that's actually out.
-Daughter's dying over there.
-I know.
It's my favorite, Black Bobcat.
I really want --
-For Boogie.
-I want you to make
"Black Bobcat."
I will do it
next time you come on.
We'll do a Black Bobcat.
But I want to talk about
something that's out there.
This is real.
You actually are opening
a restaurant in Brooklyn.
This is real close -- Swoony's
-Swoony's.
-It's a real thing.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Check it out.
-Where is this?
-Swoony's Steakhouse.
It's a speakeasy.
-Yeah. In Brooklyn?
-In Brooklyn.
In Brooklyn.
Yeah. Me and my boy Mike,
we opened up a restaurant.
Matter of fact,
when I leave here,
I got to go do a taste test
for the chef.
-Dude, that's fantastic.
Have you always wanted
to do a restaurant?
-I ain't never thought I was
gonna be opening up restaurants
and driving Ferraris.
I never thought of that.
-Yeah.
-I never seen this coming.
-No.
-I thought I was gonna be --
either be in the NFL or run the
Olympics against Carl Lewis.
[ Laughter ]
I thought I was gonna
run against Carl Lewis.
-You didn't run --
No. You never --
Did you ever meet Carl Lewis?
-I ain't never met no Carl.
[ Laughter ]
-But, dude, you actually --
you did play football.
-I did play that.
-This is the picture that
we have of you.
This is you playing.
-That was a 85-yard touchdown
against Kennedy High School.
-Really?
-Eighty -- '85.
-No way.
-Yeah, it was nice, man.
I get that from my biological
father, Tony Dorsett.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
Sounds like a good man.
-I heard Taylor Swift
like ball players.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm about to throw
the cleats back on, man.
Taylor, holler at your boy!
-No, no, no!
-I love you, Taylor!
-Tracy Morgan, everybody.
For tickets to
his stand-up show,
go to tracymorgan.com.